[Musica]
tutti abbiamo degli obiettivi delle
ambizioni dei sogni
c'è chi vuole cambiare il mondo chi
punta al successo
chi semplicemente cerca la felicità
spesso questi sogni questi obiettivi
queste ambizioni e sembrano
irrealizzabili impossibili ma c'è un
mondo un mondo dove la un mondo dove
l'impossibile è la sfida quotidiana
guardate questa foto
l'avete mai vista dice quel puntino
siamo noi
questa foto è la rappresenta la terra e
la foto più lontana che sia mai stata
scattata della terra è stata fatta dalla
sonda voyager one a della nasa nel 1990
nello spazio interstellare oltre sistema
solare a 6 miliardi di chilometri di
distanza
beh se sei miliardi di chilometri vi
sono difficili da capire da immaginare
vi posso dire in questa foto ci ha messo
più di cinque ore per arrivare qui da
noi sulla terra alla velocità della luce
voyager one non era un sogno
un'ambizione voi agevolano è stata una
missione una missione è pianificata per
ben 10 anni in ogni singola azione in un
singolo punto ogni ogni passo ogni
rischio ogni medicazione era stato
pianificato e gestito e voyager web
continua la sua missione oggi lo sta
facendo da ben 42 anni e continua
viaggiando verso l'ignoto nello spazio
interstellare
ma cos'è una missione per definizione il
compimento di una serie di azioni per
arrivare a raggiungere un obiettivo
le missioni ci vengono assegnate da
quando siamo piccoli un anno per
imparare a camminare a scuola passare
gli esami nel mondo del lavoro ci
vengono assegnate ma raramente
assegniamo una missione a noi stessi
bisogna mai chiesti qual è la vostra
missione da qui a cinque anni per
esempio quella era la vostra missione
questa mattina quando vi siete alzati
per venire qui al the beach
basta una grappa operano nel settore
dell'aerospazio faccio missioni per
lavoro mi racconto qualcuna 2011 galileo
ci lavora da quasi 20 anni
questa è la foto del primo lancio
portava i primi due satelliti galileo al
nostro sistema di navigazione
satellitare europeo tutti conoscete la
navigazione satellitare probabilmente
per il gps rosate nel vostro telefonino
per navigare quando vi scambiate la
posizione forse lo sapete che i
telefonini di ultima generazione però
hanno anche il nostro galileo europeo
li avete anche i grow nasco russo e il
baby sistema cinese il galileo usa
principalmente trasmettere i segnali
radio questo lo sapete trasmette un
segnale radio riceve il telefonino
riceve la posizione e la call call a
quello che forse non sapete che i
satelliti sono posizionati a 26.000 km
distanza e riusciamo a calcolare la
posizione con meno di un metodo di
precisione
questo equivale a prendere due volte il
diametro della terra trasmettere un
segnale radio da una parte e riuscire a
misurare il tempo di arrivo dall altra
con qualche nanosecondo di precisione
questo significa qualche miliardesimo di
secondo è incredibile ogni volta che ci
penso io dedicato quasi metà della mia
vita
la navigazione satellitare la mia
missione è sempre stata quella di
lavorare sulla sicurezza sono robustezza
di questi sistemi estate l'importanza
della sicurezza su applicazioni come
l'aeronautica per esempio quando
viaggiate in aereo durante le fasi di
cruise di viaggio di approccio agli
aeroporti
quando atterrata in mezzo alla nebbia 34
centimetri all'ora
i sistemi di navigazione satellitare
sono dei principali mezzi di
posizionamento o nel mondo della
navigazione autonoma e sono sempre più
gli scatti che consentono ad oggi auto
navigazione autonoma senza pilota in un
futuro non molto lontano potrete salire
in macchina per caffè legge di un
giornale dormire e potete arrivare
tranquillamente a destinazione ma c'è
qualcosa di più negli ultimi anni questo
sistema che era stato pensato per
funzionare presa stato progettato per
funzionare sulla terra seviziato adesso
utilizzato nello spazio il principio è
abbastanza semplice usiamo i satelliti
insomma nello spazio per calcolare la
posizione di un altro oggetto che si
trova nello spazio nella missione garis
2018 nasa ed esa attivano dato una sfida
per sviluppare il primo ricevitore gps
gare leo combinato che funzionasse sulla
stazione spaziale internazionale
la stazione spaziale internazionale lo
vedete è grande quanto un campo da
calcio vola in orbita a 400 chilometri
di altezza ospita astronauti non era mai
stato fatto prima è la sfida è stata
accettata
era la prima volta che mai stati uniti e
l'europa cooperavano insieme
con i due sistemi che funzionassero
insieme il gps americano e quello
europeo
sembrava tutto abbastanza facile fino a
quando all'inizio le attività abbiamo
scoperto che non avevamo più accesso
all'hardware e alla replica di terra che
quell'oggetto blu questa la foto
direttamente della stazione e abbiamo
dovuto ricostruire una replica locale
comprando pezzi integrando varie
soluzioni di pittura comprando pezzi
usati su internet poi a pochi mesi
dell'attività si è rotto un componente
della radio e non è mancato io stavo
proprio perché era proprio da giusto che
caricavano software sulla sua stazione
siamo riusciti a riprogrammare
l'hardware usando una seconda frequenza
che disponibili sui satelliti
abbiamo lavorato giorno e notte per
arrivare poi è successo
siamo usciti a calcolare la posizione
della stazione e in modo corretto è
abbastanza preciso le orbite e la
missione gare o 2019
la sfida era sviluppare un ricevitore
gps che rileva che funzionasse sul razzo
della nasa che andava nello spazio in
meno di un minuto e con 18 g di
accelerazione 18 g sono diciotto volte
l'accelerazione di gravità che avete qui
sulla terra quando cadete in tutto
avevamo due mesi di tempo per fare
l'elettronica il software e le campagne
di teste e qualifica a pochi minuti dal
lancio il mission control ci comunica
un'anomalia sul nostro sistema di world
avevamo pochi secondi per la reggono go
alla missione e se voi scelti tramite un
piccolo terminale satellitare a
comunicare con i colleghi dell'altra
parte del mondo eravamo nel deserto del
new mexico a novembre per dare poi il
gol finale alla missione missione che è
stato un successo razzo è nato nello
spazio
siamo riusciti a calcolare tutta la
traiettoria è stato sganciato un pezzo
il ricevitore è ritornato a terra
tramite un paracadute ed è stata
recuperata dai militari
cosa ci aspetta il futuro pensiamo che
il sistema di navigazione satellitare si
possono utilizzare anche sulla luna le
principali agenzie spaziali si stanno
lavorando per
per costruire basi lunari per costruire
gatwick e sarà una stazione spaziale kor
b per ato la luna un sogno impossibile
forse però una missione su cui stiamo
lavorando su ogni minimo dettaglio
un singolo chip che possa funzionare
sulla terra viaggiare sul razzo arrivare
sulla stazione spaziale internazionale
funzionare su tutto il transito cheese
lunare fino alla dura fino a gatwick
poter funzionare sughetto di poter
funzionare anche su un veicolo che
atterra sul suo lunario ad oggi gallè
operativo abbiamo 24 satelliti garis
missione compiuta a gara missione
compiuta incompiuta luna sfida accettata
possiamo imparare dallo spazio
le lezioni della vita e cosa si nasconde
dietro è successo di una missione la
passione prima di tutto l'amore e la
passione per quello che fate la prima
che avere successo se inseguiti i vostri
sogni
se veramente lavorate per i vostri sogni
avrete già vinto in partenza la
perseveranza non mollare mai non mollare
mai la spugna anche quando si pensa si è
perso del tutto non mollate mai
pensate al piano b al piano c sbattete
la testa ma non mollate mai
la conoscenza siamo i libri che leggiamo
le persone che frequentiamo
non possiamo pensare di smettere di
studiare di apprendere di conoscere la
conoscenza è potere e il potere non solo
come sos tentivo potere come verbo
potere fare di più poter dare di più
non c'è missione in cui si dovrebbe
tornare sui libri a studiare e
apprendere conoscere e infine è l'umiltà
siate consapevoli dei vostri limiti
delle vostre forze delle vostre capacità
accettate a sfide che vi permettono di
usare fino ai limiti dell'impossibile ma
mai oltre se veramente vogliamo cambiare
il mondo o semplicemente cercare
successo cercare la felicità
non dimentichiamo mai la passione e la
perseveranza la conoscenza el umiltà
cercate la vostra missione pianificata e
la vostra missione perché è l'unica cosa
guida l'energia e l'energia è l'unica
cosa che lascerà traccia a chi verrà
dopo di voi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]